when you understand hip hop and Street
Urban culture there is no greater
representation of culture than Snoop Dog
yeah like Snoop is like this [__] is a
[__] that was CP walking on he's done
well I mean he's done things that no
artist like no rapper has ever done and
will never do 30 not not a hip-hop
artist maybe like a drake somebody who's
not of the culture no no he's not we not
going to do that he's not of the Street
Urban culture you can't listen to music
so is Eminem not a hi-hop artist he's
from Detroit okay he's from the ghetto
okay okay Drake is a from a middle class
Canadian neighborhood so if someone
comes from a middle class family they
not hiop no so you have so you're
telling me in your eyes you have to be
from a street urban community yes in
order to be considered Hip-Hop Hip-Hop
is the first genre of music forgive me
because I know everybody better listen
to P like go you can't kick me it's not
the point I'm saying hip hop is Street
Urban artistic expression so
didn't well I mean we could probably
really nitpick this this discussion and
then I'm going kind of yeah I'm
going Drake's been popped Drake is kind
of popped that's a different statement
but to say somebody in my top five okay
somebody in my top five I've had that
and I'm glad you said Kanye West did not
grow up in the hood and I've been
thinking this whole time he his mother
was a teacher and I've been thinking
whole time I was like is he really cuz I
think as much as he's in my top five and
I appreciate him I think he is the
problem do you think Diddy is hip-hop
Puff Daddy no puff is an executive so
you don't think Puff Daddy is hip-hop no
I think puff put out hip-hop X but he is
hip-hop I don't know if he's responsible
for so much history Jimmy
a yeah but did is did he produce records
yeah really yeah has he really in the
same way Quincy Jones has produced
records yes really he puts the right
people together in the forgive me
forgive me Diddy puff my bad look I
don't know but Kanye has been my my
greatest dilemma but if you think about
it right this is going to sound crazy so
Kanye is in my top five cuz I love you
know I think the world of Kanye there
were times I I've expressed to charlot
man I think Kanye is a prophet for
living so I think this much of him but
if you think about his first single like
he got into a car crash great record
like All American car crash with
insurance yeah but what's wrong with
that that's nothing it's like Madonna
could have made that song that's not
true yes it's a middle class song about
a man get into a car accident with
insurance so you're saying there there
can't be middle class raps yes Drake is
a fantastic rapper fantastic non-stop is
my [__] but that don't mean they are hip
hop Street Urban culture now a lot of
people disagree with me some people like
long as you practice what them [__] do
then you're one of those [__] but you
know how I feel about that but but my
point is with Kanye right you would kick
out like half a hip-hop fast that then
you'd say you aren't hip-hop fast
because I'm going tell you why because
look what happened to rock and roll MH
it ain't a [__] in
sight look what happened to
Jazz cuz soon as you start letting
everybody in the door guess who getting
kicked out first I don't think that's
ever going to happen in hipop guaranteed
they've tried it's h it's only been it's
only been 50 years they they've been
putting out records for 40 it's guarant
to happen I'm not sure there's uh you
know what's funny is I've always thought
to myself like who's the white you know
like who's the white that's like the
white of whites in Hip Hop that like can
actually make this thing work like and
like sustainable long time let's get rid
of Eminem cuz Eminem is an alien yeah
he's like a anomaly in the world 30 40
years ago Eminem would have been a punk
rock here it's Eminem by the way yeah
right if you were to say it it's Eminem
but but we had this conversation hip hop
and punk rock are brothers Step Brothers
right right uh uh um same father
oppression and poverty different mothers
the area the Earth so you so CU because
this is there's a lot of artists who
have families that went to college that
had middle class jobs lot people from
together went to college no at middle
class middle class areas little yachty
yeah but would you really do you look at
little yachty and be like oh that's a
hip-hop guy yeah no you just only feel
like that cuz he raps no I think he I
think he's hip-hop for sure yeah but I'm
saying because he raps if he and I also
think he's also contributed a lot to
culture he's he wrote city girls act up
he kind of kicked off lowkey this whole
[__] yeah but so did Jimmy IV so it's a
lot of other people but not in the same
way Jimmy I what song did Jimmy iven
write but don't that's not again you're
you're me there's people outside of the
culture who have wrote cultured songs
okay let me ask you a
question you're so cuz cuz I feel that
there has been and I'm not saying I know
of little yachty's hip hop I don't know
little yach there has been an uptick in
completely in what it's a complete
takeover of middle class people ever
since the blog era happened yes soon as
college kids started dictating what was
cool within Street Urban culture you
seen the change because it became the
guys that they could deal with yeah but
to me that's still hip-hop that's not
that's just music hip-hop is the culture
like if you don't talk like if you don't
talk like us how and there's the five
elements of Hip Hop no no no those are
expressions how you express the culture
so I just think that like if you look at
a guy I'm trying to think of a guy you
said the blog ER so I'm just trying to
think Kanye is the greatest conversation
and as one of my favorite guys and it's
one of your favorite guys yeah and Kanye
is probably the most influential artist
of the last I don't know 30 years who
did he influence Class
People Travis Scott is hip-hop middle
class people I don't even think Travis
Scott considers himself hip-hop that's
not true I don't I don't think so have
you did you listen to the drums on the
new album um again drums are not
exclusive to hip-hop I know but just you
know they've been having hard drums and
house and a lot of other stuff that hip
hop birth okay so outside of but I'm not
again I haven't studied all of those
guys to say their [__] specifically I've
been saying this about Kanye and I think
that's why I mean Kanye did influence a
sound that kind of I mean him and just
blaze fingerprints all over the
blueprint it's really BL though it's who
[__] well [__] started it everybody
start following [__] okay so if you
listen to the blueprint right yeah and
then after the blueprint everyone
started sampling but it's all based off
[__]
okay this is it's important to know this
truth and and they all I think that's an
opinion though no this is a fact I don't
think you can say that like just blaze
and Kanye weren't chopping up samples
before [__] they wasn't doing it the way
they were doing it on a blueprint before
[__] that style that's that sound that
was birthed out of that is [__]
well the credit goes to
bank I'm saying the general public would
credit the blueprint as the album that
kicked off a sonic wave of like people
sampling sure like high pitch samples
again again I'm with you I'm all in I'm
just saying there's a fact and then
there's a ignorance okay so are you
telling me Kanye is not hip-hop I'm
telling you that's that's been my
dilemma right because cuz he is hip-hop
well this is the problem right he's
Kanye West but that doesn't mean
anything it that don't mean first off
nobody in [__] hip hop put Marilyn
Maro up on their [__] wall as a kid
what do what's I don't understand the
correlation between Kanye and Marilyn
Monroe cuz he talked about putting up a
poster cuz of Marilyn Monroe on his wall
what's wrong with that why the [__]
would a [__] from where we from put up
Marilyn Marone they wall cuz they think
she's hot no none of us think she's hot
that you're speaking for a lot of people
from the ghetto I speak for all of us
I'm sure a lot of people in the ghetto
would clap her chees none of yes we
would anybody's but we wouldn't think
she's hot it's too many hot [__]
sisters from that time he Compares Kim
Kardashian to her like yeah but Kim K is
is lovely you don't you don't no she's
not you don't think Kim K is lovely no
she was okay she was a regular you think
she was okay yeah she was a regular they
used to have him in Glendale by the by
the
barrel there was Kim Kardashians by the
barrel by the Barrel in Glendale that's
that's the normal fine girl in Glend
that's the normal fine girl in Glendale
When you go to the scenes I'm in
Glendale a lot yeah I live in in burb
they just don't have the plastic money
well I just don't see I've seen I don't
see by the barrel I I see them by the
Barr shout out to the beautiful Armenian
women who are in they're great they're
fine and they Kim kard yes they are they
Kim Kardashian fine all of them original
Kim Kardashian I not this version I
don't know what's going on I'm not
saying that there aren't some Kim
Kardashian fine Armenian I'm just saying
that I think that you're uh you're
overstating your point no no no I'm
telling you the truth listen if you
think about it right listen to every
other thing you loved about hip-hop
growing up right the struggle the the
the the ideas even how they party I
liked hey you know what I liked what
first of all I love doggy style sure and
the other album that really I like the
kind of like the
horror demonic Mystique of Bone Thugs
and
Harmony the Ouiji are you
with it was the melody that did it for
you know they the Mr IGI and you know
what else I liked what they had the best
Harmony since be boys probably had like
fantastic Harmony I mean I can tell you
like from creeping on a come up to East
1999 Art of War man God Bon again
somehow criminally underrated super uh I
also really enjoyed Brother Lynch Hung
Lynch is dope I got that [__] for about
four zones I had to get dirty on brother
Lynch had to I always give props of his
album season of The Sickness it was a
very uh dark album where he talked about
eating I like Lynch yeah I [__] with
Lynch Lynch is a nut but the point I'm
saying back to yay right here so brother
Lynch hip
hop uh I would imagine so he's from like
a really [__] up get on sack but him
talking about eating children but I
think he also created would not be the
something that a normal dude from the
hood would talk about well it's not I
mean he's like he's like um edar Allen
po also also Bone Thugs in harmony
talking about playing around with a
Ouija board and to uh the you know
that's not that farfetched for people
that's not you you used a Maryland
Monroe poster on the wall I'm saying
let's start with Kanye growing up in
middle class area in Chicago so that's
different than bone and Bone and
Cleveland Brother Lynch and Sack them
them people are from places houses was
$13 for sure right so that's different
houses might have been $13 in Chicago
the houses is $13 in Cleveland right you
can get house in Cleveland right now for
about 7,000 let me know where duplex I
got you I got you go there bone grew up
at yeah shout out to uh the Cavaliers so
so what my point I'm saying to you is
I'm not I haven't came to a great
conclusion it's Kanye West so it's hard
to challenge that type of Legacy but if
you think about it but if you think
about it right his first song is about a
car crash where he had insurance but
what got everybody is the [__] black
music he sampled in Shaka Khan MH that
carries the story Kanye is the best at
using black music and finding a place
where he meets black people at remember
hip hop is almost like you think Kanye
makes he's a black artist yes but but
when you say black right it's it's it's
as simple as he's a black man making
music right but he's not the first
artist to sample black artists no no but
he's he's fantastic at it yeah when I'm
tell you what he does with that Shaka
Khan and but if you listen to a lot of
his songs even the depth of his struggle
is very Eddie Winslow but you know what
it was what was dope about Kanye is is
that his struggle was relatable to white
people to a lot of people to mainstream
America cuz if you could talk about how
you hated working at the mall at the Gap
that's like
main no okay but but but like imagine if
snoop's first album is about him talking
about having a problem working at the
what made but that's what made Kanye
different was he was a [__] pop
artist you could relate to him versus
you couldn't relate to none of these he
was not a pop artist he was making some
backpack dope rap [__] but he was
talking about backpack to work at theall
because this is the the minority of the
of
everybody aren't in gangs and aren't
involved in street life and not but
whether or not they grew up around it
would you would you at least say that
most people period no matter what the
race of them or the or where they're
from are not tied up in street life are
civilians is that fair most they're not
from the ghetto okay people from the
ghetto have normal jobs at the mall hand
no they don't have them at the mall but
they do have normal jobs are you trying
to tell me people from the ghetto don't
work at the mall yes but that's not
that's a wild thing to say that's a very
wild blanket statement you're you're
pushing it further right let's what I'm
saying is most of us work Kanye made an
made music for the normal person that's
what pop music is no pop music listen
this is what you got to understand is
that not what pop music is cuz for the
everyday person no but you're trying to
you're essentially trying to say well
Kanye was making music for uh privileged
people who had normal jobs I did not
first off yes it's not you're not
privileged if you have a normal job that
makes you mainstream American but even
people let's say from where you're from
right but that but but even then now
you're talking about I'm asking you so
people from where you're from right
let's say your neighborhood what
percentage of them are actively
throughout their life
practicing involvement in
let's say Street culture illegal
activity gangs we all talk the same way
so that's I'm not talking about talk I'm
talking about I'm talking about how you
get your money the lifestyle you live
you can't pick the part of a culture you
enjoy right cuz de soul is culture right
but it don't mean that it don't mean
somebody probably people from your area
down who had to get up and go to work
and do their normal job I got homies
that got jobs that Kanye [__] and was
like yo this dude's talking about
working a [__] overtime shift at a
retail store this is pop music no it's
not that's normal middle class [__]
that's what pop America is so you're
trying to say Kanye wasn't making
hip-hop that's not what I'm saying I
have I told you I've been having this
dilemma in my mind to say that so so you
make a lot of blanket statements no I'm
I'm giving you really consistent
statements consistent considering all of
your statements according to your logic
Kanye is not hip-hop I'm thinking about
it I've been I've been on this PL cuz
I've been saying for years he's hip-hop
but then I think about it I'm like
that's why black America is disconnected
from him right now they like well I
think they also might be disconnected
cuz he said some wild [__] no he did he
said the same [__] he been saying since
the first day and he has been wrapped up
in a very
unrelatable
culture whether it's the Kardashians
whether it's you know why huh cuz he
ain't that type of guy but he was that
type of guy no he wasn't he was just
doing it over Shaka Khan and the other
thing well okay that's my point that's
what I'm starting to believe so like he
always been this crazy [__] Kanye is
like so so do you think Playboy card's
hip hop no okay I got to ask but he got
some dope [__] the first song but all
that weird devil [__] I had to slap
little cuz like all that ho ass [__]
they doing with the devil that'll be CU
be I don't like that yeah I know you do
I hate that you love you some L Nas X
though no no l Nas is cool cuz he just
fake gay I told you you going to see one
day it's going to come out cuz fake gay
what does that mean he's playing for the
money so you don't think little no
no I don't believe cuz is gay I believe
they paying cuz and he know his play and
he running his play why would you not
it's [__] who do it in gangster rap
it's [__] who do it like they fake D
boys why would you not be fake gay for
money especially if you young why is it
more people been fake gay for money then
they it has been people fake gay for
money fake gay yeah lot of fake fake the
gayness easy you act gay for people like
a fake gangster rapper like a [__] who
act like he a gangster but he's not I
think there's probably more fake
straight people than fake gay people I
would agree yeah ID agree for I for sure
would agree but that don't mean Lil NX
is not straight I think little NX is uh
is gay I don't believe that and I think
it's he's gay facing you think he's gay
I know we talked about this last time
but I I just don't know if that's a
that's I don't know if that's the uh
that's that's what my that's on my w if
he really wanted to like lean into
something he would have just been the
country artist he couldn't you know
that's not gonna work no white folks
ain't [__] with that [__] bro they did
when Oldtown roog came they
didn't I don't know money man where's he
from money man money man you listen I
don't I haven't I haven't so listen so
first off I can't talk about Travis
Scott but I think Travis Scott has
defined his sound but I think he defines
his sound as uh what is like Rave or uh
what's that rage rage no he's making
hip-hop but he's defined his music Uzi
defines his music is rock and roll I
think Uzi defines himself as a rock star
yeah that makes rock music no he doesn't
make rock music yes but again this is my
point see see how you see how you laying
claim to that see how you won't let
[__] be nothing else but rappers cuz
they dogs a rockar yeah but but no he's
not what do you mean he's not he's Snoop
Dog he's in the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame he's in every Hall of Fame yes cuz
he's Hall of f he's a hip hop star he's
a rock star he's a pop star he is the
guy yeah but but let me make my point
before we get lost listen I I haven't
studied none none of those other guys so
I can't comment per on yachty CU I don't
know yachty story I don't know tra story
I don't know them but I don't think they
Define themselves and I think they will
maybe yachi would be the closest person
that could consider himself hip-hop or
would well his dad was a big
photographer he did photos for dead
press uh but he didn't grow up like like
from what I understand he grew up like
with you know like a middle class kid
yeah and I'm not saying I don't I don't
know I had to really study it before I
say that Trav I think he defines his
music as something else and I think U
defines his music and his existence as
something else but I think because they
use rap immediately everybody classifies
somebody black in rapping as hip-hop and
it's [__] [__] up if Uzi Uzi as
black people created rock and roll right
he can go in and defin it as he want
that's his claim to rights you can't
look at Nirvana or no YouTu and then say
he got to make music like that we did it
the first time so we can redefine it the
second time okay it's fair of him to do
that but what I'm saying is back to the
point we were saying in my neighborhood
being in in Street urban life is not
necessarily you know being a criminal
like there's a lot of people like LL
wasn't a criminal there's people who
grew up in the same cultur well what I'm
saying though is that there are people
who aren't criminals who maybe they're
they're gravitating they gravitated
towards College Dropout because oh this
is something different I'm not disag
this is this is actually I liked it as a
criminal but that's not the point I like
Michael Jack I like a lot of pop artists
but I'm saying like if I like to me as
somebody who was working a Best Buy when
I was 16 I was like oh [__] I get it
this [__] is rapping about
working at a shitty retail job bet you
do get it that's my point I'm saying so
what I'm saying is but I grew up I
didn't grew up middle class I grew up
poor as [__] I know you did cuz Fenix
got some [__] crazy sick ass poor
places yeah they do yeah sick that
nobody talks about sick some crazy [__]
shout out to fix cuz they go through
some [__] nobody talks about it true but
the point I'm saying to you is when we
saying this it's
like everybody that grow up with us talk
the same way everybody who grows up with
us eats the same way every Everybody
grow that's not but that's not Universal
that's where you're at right but but
that's all Street Urban culture it's the
way the people in Atlanta are different
people in Gary Indiana are different
every ghetto people in Cleveland are
different every ghetto there is no
middle class culture there only
tradition in middle class and in wealth
there is no culture so therefore how
could you have hip-hop somewhere where
there's no culture so if Drake let's say
Drake for example shout out to D do you
think the Beasty Boys are are hip-hop no
they punk rock that made a hip-hop album
okay do you think licens to Ill is
hip-hop yes they made a hip-hop album
okay so that's hip-hop I agree because
but they actually punk rock they started
as punk rockers punk rock and Hip-Hop
right are Step Brothers okay Run DMC a
what they're hip-hop listen correct
they're of course do you do you do you
think that Run
DMC like obviously L Run DMC is kind of
looked at as like the first like I would
would you say like pop hip hop group in
terms of like their popularity in terms
of popularity when we use the word yeah
yeah I guess to some degree
um would you discount them working with
AOS Smith because no I don't think I
think you can work with whoever you want
to but I think Hip Hop is more as much
as Street Urban culture is defined
through crime and and densely populated
crime rid neighborhoods it don't mean
everyone's a criminal I didn't say I
didn't say that was the case which was
my point not everyone's a criminal
so I feel like you were pretty much
saying n where we're from this is what
we we we don't [__] with regular Mall
jobs no that we we're we're denied Mall
jobs that's not true yes have you been
in the mall yes I've been to the mall in
the worst areas yes yes yes I got some
of the my worst type of friends working
at the mall steal it out of the back of
a foot Lo I'm not saying that allegedly
back in the day I'm saying the poverty
and the oppression here's a here's a
here's a here's a Richard conversation
but let me get that point off I'm saying
we're all the cultures created through
the crime the crime happening to
everybody whether you involved or not
you know what the crime that is to
education programs to where the
education programs are trash and you
don't speak great English so y'all make
up slang and y'all all talk the same way
it don't matter if cuz got a job at the
mall in the hood or if he's selling dope
we all talk the same we all got the same
lingo we all do the same thing I this is
the this is what I likened it to and
this gonna be crazy because you know
you're a white man in this conversation
is funny you're a [__] but you're a
white man
the point I'm saying to you is there's
always been three black cultures in
America right or three the ideas of
three identities there's a slave you
know American slave culture right that's
where you get sold food that's where you
get all that there's a freed men since
the first day black people been on this
planet especially in this country
there's been free black people and then
there's been slave masters a smaller
culture of black people it's not a
culture it's a tradition of life that
really small minut of black slavers
right that's their small Freeman slaves
Kanye is a Freeman his whole whole
conversation is Freeman he has no idea
what [__] from where we from are
talking about that's why you'll say
something like slavery is a choice Kanye
reminds me of a kid that got to visit
his cousins on the plantation it was
like we need to leave here once this
weekend when I go home y'all go with me
that makes sense that's how he talks cuz
his mind and that's what middle class
does to you it creates a place to where
the world is Limitless the world is not
like like your world is not real to them
it's the upside down right okay that's
fair that's what hip hop is but again
because people want a piece of it and
it's like it's something seems so cool
they want a piece of the lingo they want
a piece of the get down but they don't
want a piece of the consequence that's
why I'm really careful with who I say
and who I believe represents me as a
ghetto person from Hip Hop now if I
start allowing somebody like Drake
forgive me Drake again shout out to the
homies it's no disrespect but if you
don't speak not one thing on what's
going on with black people in this
country not one stance not one that's
been my biggest critique I don't even
care cuz he's Canadian right but I I
just I just feel like he doesn't ever
have an opinion on anything but except
now he's wearing rainbow Clips so you're
endorsing movements but you're not
endorsing the people that put you in
position to be where you at now yeah I I
do think it's like interesting that like
like why you don't have shade for no why
your shade is for Joe bu he he not first
off a rich Jewish man right bragging
about being Rich to some [__] that come
from the ghetto like Joe
butons that [__] is like cringy whereas
like well I just think I mean I said
this on Twitter the other day I said uh
I don't think Joe Buton said anything
that was unfair or disrespectful and I'm
not mad and I'm not mad at Drake being
offended at his critique of cuz Dr I'm a
little I'm a little mad at that because
I feel like Drake bro you have to
understand like people are going to have
an opinion about your music and as long
as they're not crossing the line or
they're not saying and he should be able
to have an opinion about them but my
thing is why does it go right to what
you have or money like you're like Drake
is actually a talent talented
accomplished MC record making [__]
monster yeah why go to money I have a
private jet and you have to take first
class flights because you're a rich
Jewish man right that's like being a
broke black person it's like that's how
common to to to the main ears that
sounds it's like you going to talk about
a [__] being broke yeah it wasn't
necessary for sure so I'm not mad at him
but he could have talked about so many
things you know what I mean and that's
what hip-hop is it's bearing the burden
of Street Urban culture you have to
represent right see when you don't have
when you don't have to represent nobody
Jay could have never went out like that
because he represented Mars in Brooklyn
he had to that's the only way he could
Garner support Snoop could never you you
know another reason why Snoop is such a
fantastic hip-hop artist he will never
break cripping he defs crippin how he
wants that's what crippin is all about
you know what I'm saying long as you
don't break them that one rule about no
snitches you can do with crippin as you
please just don't make nobody look dumb
and Snoop has done a great job of not
making people look stupid and he never
broke away when you don't have to bear
the burden of culture when you don't got
to represent hip hop is all about
representing the people we talking about
do they [__] represent do do people
from their Community feel like this is
our spokesman when talk rest assured any
real [__] from watch most [__] from
watchs like that [__] is all right
[__] from La going to be like glasses
is all right cuz I I have to I can't do
no sucker [__] how I'mma show my face in
the 60s how I'mma show my face in a
trads how I'mma show my faces in the
great streets how I'mma show my face and
East coastes if I go looking dumb I have
the burden of representing ghettos
that's what hip-hop is LL had the
responsibility LL and Nas had to
represent Queens 50 had to represent
Southside Queens Jay had to represent
Brooklyn if you don't got to represent
[__] and you can still be successful
[__] you are not one of us if you can
embarrass us every week you don't think
that Drake represents Toronto no all
right not the streets I mean he
represents Toronto as the Raptors
represent Toronto and he's their guy
like I think Drake my problem is Drake
represent black people right and we be
looking like cuz what are you
doing you know what I mean like what the
[__] cuz why would you do that but the
problem is when we tryy to hold him with
our ghetto respons he's not a ghetto kid
he don't come from the ghetto he don't
if you got to think morale and Street
Life create standards create
morals you know what I mean the religion
excuse me and Street Life create morals
without it America is just like a dog
eat dog place right they [__]
up yeah I think we can at times be
unfair towards Drake because he is such
a just just massive shining star in in
hip-hop I think that at times Drake does
things where I'm like okay you're like
being a little too emotional towards Joe
but and like to Discount him as like a
failed rapper unfair don't I I don't I
don't I don't really care about that I I
do think though I what I care about is
them [__] hair clips see I don't I
don't care yeah if you go on to dors why
don't you like the hair clips because
why you do Snoop Dog had had had a lot
of [__] going on with his hair and
showed the sugarfree yeah but they ain't
putting rainbow hair clip that's a
purpose he's doing a lot of things on
purpose to do certain things and I'm
asking you why you ain't stood up for no
[__] if you going to stand up for
somebody who you going to represent you
who's he representing you think he's
representing the the alphabet boys you
know he is and that's his thought I
don't think so then why would you put
rainbow hair clips in your head why does
Rainbow got to be exclusive to something
that that it it ain't a God it's just
what if he bought a pack of hair clips
and they came in multiple colors why
does everything have to have a specific
meaning or agenda attached to it Drake's
hair clips don't mean anything except
for their hair clips you really believe
that do you think Drake purposely said
nah give me the rainbow pack yes no
that's crazy you don't believe Drake
Drake is like one of the greatest Minds
like Kanye in let me tell you something
not see the problem is is let me just
say this the problem
is certain like in 2023 for whatever
reason we always have to put a meaning
or stick some sort of agenda to
something that it don't got nothing to
do with because we all know it means
something it doesn't it does it's just
hair clips no it doesn't it's not are
you serious it's not if I were so you do
you think Drake's hairclips are him
endorsing a certain lifestyle yes really
yes and it's the mainstream thing to do
what does that mean that's the thing to
do at a MST level across the world
that's what every pop artist would be
doing across the world that people not C
this not by accident you think this [__]
by this [__] is brilliant like like
Drake is so what is Drake's agenda with
his colorful haircut now we going to go
into some details but obviously what
what is your uh perceived agenda
obviously endorsing right which I don't
care about that but my thing is the
[__] who made you famous These [__]
In America these ghettos cuz we pushed
cuz like he couldn't just be a pop star
and be that we pushed cuz the ghettos
push cuz we said the females the black
women from the ghettos push CS you ain't
said nothing about nothing happening to
these Sisters You Ain't posting is
happening to these you not saying
nothing about no [__] and I got let
that go cuz you was Canadian I'm like
you know what he don't have to give [__]
what happened to American [__] I don't
disagree with you sure on that point cuz
I do think at at certain points in time
it'd be nice if we knew what Drake
thought about I don't know George Floyd
or bana Taylor I'm not even asking that
cuz most pop artist or or or you know he
lives here a lot yeah like there's a lot
of turmoil going on with our political
system just any sort of opinion and I'm
okay with that but like you said he's
Canadian yes what do you think about
Justin Trudeau Drake facts facts facts
what do you think about the Canadian
truck drivers who I'm not mad because
that's a hip-hop responsibility okay
okay but so I think that's separate than
you thinking that there's an agenda with
his hair clips you missing a point of
somebody that's so brilliant to know not
to speak on something he's so this [__]
him and 40 are some of the best
scientists I ever seen in the music
business like when it comes to creating
records marketing and understand how to
Market Dr like Michael Jordan right like
Michael Jordan purposely has said said
Republicans and Democrats buy both my
sneakers why would I take a stance on
any of this publicly cuz then I I kind
of and Drake's kind of the same kind of
guy yeah but but Drake Drake appeals to
everybody and I don't think he wants to
[__] that up and and I'm not mad at that
but my thing is right that's why you
know who else does that pop
stars yeah I mean there's also artists
there's no hip-hop artists that do that
we won't even let them go we won't even
Nick if you try that if you try that and
you represent us it's a problem wait a
minute you're not going to speak up Thug
say something like oh we ain't talking
about that [__] we talking about young
[__] they was asking Thug about the
boy that got killed Mike uh in Ohio
what's brother yeah yeah um Mike uh
Michael Mike Brown Michael Brown m brown
Michael Brown and it was like yeah you
know he was on a red carpet like you
know how you feel about Mike Brown like
oh man we ain't tripping off that old
politics [__] we out here getting [__]
fell apart oh my God you [__] and
this [__] is a [__] who do drugs he I
don't even think we should even really
want his opinion cuz he go through so
much mental [__] and be high you yeah
yeah you're not going to look to Thug
for political views but he still has to
cuz guess why he is from the ghetto in
Atlanta and we like you better talk you
better speak for us and that's the
responsibility of Hip Hop I don't give a
[__] if it's tribe de Soul anybody you
are responsible for speaking for us in
Hip
Hop okay so and if you don't we look at
you funny but the only people we don't
worry about it's people that ain't hip
hop so what's the issue with uh with the
hair clips nothing I have no issues with
it I'm saying this is I'm asking you
this is the first you are so you are
offici your stance is he's purposely
from the nails the hair he's going to
keep going okay so do you think Andre
3000 was doing that in 9697 when when
when he was wearing
certain I just think he got Erica bad
[__] and that [__] is some [__] okay
Drake ain't got no Erica bad [__] what
about Thug when th War dress on his
album cover yeah I think Thug is from
Atlanta where the street Urban culture
is tied into homosexuality that for some
reason nobody in Atlanta talks about
it's like right there like I've never
seen a bigger demographic of gay black
folks in the ghetto like Atlanta never
seen that do you think it's possible
Drake just got a bag of hair clips no
zero chance okay he's too smart he too
smart to just do something and don't
have no idea it's impossible it's it's
impossible
z0 0% 0% not even a half a percent
chance he just put some hair clips in
his hair and they happen to be different
colors no zero chance what zero
chance he's Drake Drake is brilliant dog
there's a confusion Drake is [__]
brilliant dog him and 40 together dog
them [__] could put [__] together the
[__] 40 or 40 the producer 40 the
producer like he could come with [__]
bro they could push it together like
some of the [__] they be doing music i'
be like [__] like you know what I mean
because you got to catch up to this [__]
and it's like
[__] like this is how smart they are
he's a marketing [__] machine you
know what I mean he knows
well I think that you're re reaching I
understand why you feel that way because
it would actually mean you would have to
be accountable for decisions you make no
I just and we love a world where we
could just make people unable think but
in Hip Hop we have to be accountable I
just think not everything famous people
does has an agenda attached to it I know
because you which it don't make sense
because you would think that some of
these people are some of the greatest
marketing Minds ever
and you would think that they would
accidentally do something even though
they've been controlling the narrative
for 20 years okay Switching subjects
shout out to Drake yeah shout out to
Jersy